hinter den kulissen von experimenten und
forschungsarbeiten passiert auch immer
jede menge unfug
heute haben wir für euch die top 5 sein
sales im englischsprachigen raum ist der
hashtag viel werk fehlt weit verbreitet
unter diesem hashtag twittern jede menge
wissenschaftler und forscher über ihre
kleinen bzw auch manchmal etwas größeren
missgeschicke fünf davon haben wir heute
für euch herausgesucht und fangen wir
mal mit einem schon einigermaßen
schrägen vorfall an
also auf der 5 juli hecht nimmt immer
wieder urinproben von hunden was kann da
schon groß passieren fragt ihr euch
natürlich hat sie keiner der hunde
absichtlich angebracht sondern es war
einfach etwas windig ein kurzer
kräftiger windstoß reichte um julie zu
besudeln schaden genommen hat dabei
natürlich keiner aber beim nächsten
missgeschick wurde es den betroffenen
zumindest ein bisschen heiß auf der 4
steigern wir uns also jeder taucher
brauchte zusätzliches gewicht
normalerweise legt man sich da zu einem
gürtel der mit gewichten bestimmt ist an
dr allister darf war vermutlich auch auf
einem tauchgang als er diesen tweet
gesendet hat folgendes hatte er aber
nicht dabei eben den wake welt also den
gürtel mit den gewichten diesen ersetzte
er dann durch ganz natürliche
materialien steine
das problem die steine die er sich in
die hose steckte waren steine die mit
feuer korallen in berührung gekommen
waren heißer scheiß
der mann ist wirklich nicht
beneidenswert
die drei jetzt wird's wirklich
unangenehm
agatha daniel witt hat nichts vergessen
außer vielleicht an wen sie einen radio
transmitter anbringen wollte eigentlich
wollte sie den transmitter an ein
krokodil kleben
das gelang auch warum aber haben sie
nicht mehr von dem krokodil weg die arme
hat sich gleich mit daran geklebt dass
man danach auch noch die ruhe hat
darüber humorvoll zu twittern kommt wohl
nicht allzu oft vor
wir nähern uns mit der zweite im
höhepunkt das aguias tanjevic die ruhe
hatte zu twittern ist ja schon
bemerkenswert aber es geht noch
außergewöhnlicher in den wäldern von
tansania stießen treffer jones und sein
begleiter auf einem löwen
nein sie waren nicht dort um höfen
auszukundschaften eigentliches ziel der
reise war es affen aufzuspüren und zu
beobachten
jetzt kam es zu einem kleinen
rollentausch der löwe beobachtete die
forscher also nicht die forscher den
löwen
diese flüchteten dann auf einem baum das
ist aber noch lange nicht die ernte der
baum war nämlich kein baum sondern eher
ein bäumchen das gab nach und sie waren
schneller wieder bei den löwen als sie
davor flüchten konnten
doch was geschah dann dem löwen wurde
das ganze etwas zu bunt und er lief
davon
ein glück dass die beiden an einen
schreckhaften löwen geraten sind
der mega phelan einen definitiv nicht
schreckhaften jaguar geriet angel maria
bei jonas i verärgerte einen jaguar
gewaltig wie als sie sich auf der reise
erleichtern musste tat sie das
ausgerechnet an einem baum den eben
dieser jaguar nutzte um sein revier zu
kennzeichnen
begeistert darüber war der jaguar auf
keinen fall für ihn war das ganz klar er
muss sein revier verteidigen also machte
er sich auf das wesen auch zu spüren
dass ihm sein revier streitig gemacht
hatte drei wochen lang verfolgte das
tier die forscherin
wie sich das wohl an gefühlt haben muss
wenn man nach dem hashtag field workfare
sucht findet man noch viele weitere
solche geschichten mehr zu fünf
verblüffenden fakten zur pubertät
erfahrt ihr im video hier oben zu rap
und zum block kommt er hier unten
und würdet ihr euch freuen wenn wir
häufiger für euch solche kleinen stars
raussuchen und euch präsentieren lasst
es uns in den kommentaren wissen und
vielleicht habt ihr auch eine lustige
forscher story schreibt sie rein und was
bleibt mir noch bis dann bleibt dran